Last year, we ran an episode about face blindness. People who are faceblind have trouble recognizing the faces of even their closest friends and family members. They're at one end of a spectrum of facial recognition ability, and today we're going to talk about the people at the other end of that bell curve, the super recognizers, or people who never forget a face. Scientists only began to study super recognizers a little over a decade ago, and since then, they've learned a great deal about this extraordinary ability. They've also begun to explore, together with police departments and other security organizations and businesses, how super recognizers might contribute to police investigations and other security work. So how well can super recognizers remember faces?
去年，我们做了一期关于面孔失认症的节目。面孔失认症患者即使是面对最亲近的朋友和家人，也难以认出他们的脸。他们处于面部识别能力光谱的一端，而今天我们要讨论的是处于钟形曲线另一端的人，即“超级识别者”，也就是那些过目不忘的人。科学家们在十多年前才开始研究超级识别者，从那时起，他们对这种非凡的能力有了很多了解。他们还开始与警察部门、其他安全组织及企业合作，探索超级识别者如何为警务调查和其他安全工作做出贡献。那么，超级识别者的面部记忆能力到底有多强呢？
Can they really recognize a person whom they saw for only a few minutes many years ago? Are super recognizers as good as computer facial recognition algorithms? And can you train yourself to be a super recognizer, or at least improve your own facial recognition ability? Or is this something you have to be born with? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. We have two guests today. Our first is Dr. Josh Davis, a professor of applied psychology at the University of Greenwich in London.
他们真的能认出多年前只见过几分钟的人吗？超级识别者和计算机面部识别算法相比，谁更厉害？你可以通过训练让自己成为一名超级识别者，或者至少提高自己的面部识别能力吗？还是说这必须是天生的？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。今天我们有两位嘉宾。第一位是伦敦格林威治大学应用心理学教授乔什·戴维斯博士。
Dr. Davis began his research career studying facial recognition ability and eyewitness identification. Since 2011, he has focused mainly on understanding super recognizers exceptional abilities in this area. He's developed screening tests to help better identify super recognizers, and he works with police departments and other organizations around the world to explore the ways in which super recognizers can contribute to security work. Our second guest is Kelly Despera. Ms. Despera has always had an extraordinary ability to recognize and remember faces, but she didn't know that she was a super recognizer until about four years ago,
戴维斯博士的研究生涯始于面部识别能力和目击者辨认。自2011年以来，他主要致力于了解超级识别者在这一领域的非凡能力。他开发了筛选测试，以帮助更好地识别超级识别者，并与世界各地的警察部门和其他组织合作，探索超级识别者为安全工作做出贡献的方式。我们的第二位嘉宾是凯莉·德斯佩拉。德斯佩拉女士一直拥有非凡的面部识别和记忆能力，但直到大约四年前，她才知道自己是一名超级识别者，
when she took the online super recognizer screening test and received the highest score that researchers had ever seen. Today, she works for a company called Super Recognizers International, which trains and employs Super Recognizers to assist with everything from murder investigations to security at sporting events. Thank you both for joining us today. Hi, Kim. Nice to see you. Hello. Thank you very much for inviting us. It's very exciting. All right. So we're going to go with first names here just to keep it on a little informal basis. So, Josh, let's start with you. How do you identify and define a super recogniser and how good does someone have to be at recognising faces to qualify?
当时她参加了在线超级识别者筛选测试，并获得了研究人员所见过的最高分。如今，她就职于一家名为“国际超级识别者”的公司，该公司负责培训和聘用超级识别者，协助处理从谋杀调查到体育赛事安保等各项事务。感谢两位今天加入我们的节目。你好，金。很高兴见到你。你好。非常感谢邀请我们。这太令人兴奋了。好的。那我们就用名字来称呼彼此，保持一点非正式的氛围。那么，乔什，我们先从你开始。你如何识别和定义一名超级识别者？一个人需要多擅长识别人脸才能获得这个资格？
On the whole, we've sort of set a rather arbitrary standard for super recognition that people should be able to. to be in the top 2% of the population, achieving scores, should I say, on four primary criteria. Short-term face memory, long-term face memory, simultaneous face matching, which is the art of passport officers checking identity documents that the person in front of them is the person they say they are, and also spotting faces in a crowd. And we expect super recognisers to be in the top 2% on all four criteria. Kelly, did you always know this was something that you were very, very good at? How did you first recognise that you had an extraordinary ability that everybody else didn't have? I had no idea. I had no idea that I was doing anything different to anybody
总的来说，我们为超级识别者设定了一个相当随意的标准，即人们应该能够进入人口的前2%，在四个主要标准上取得成绩。这四个标准是：短期面部记忆、长期面部记忆、同步面部匹配（即护照官员检查身份证件，确认面前的人就是证件上的人），以及在人群中发现面孔。我们要求超级识别者在这四个标准上都达到前2%。凯莉，你一直都知道自己在这方面非常非常擅长吗？你是怎么第一次意识到自己拥有别人所没有的非凡能力的？我完全不知道。我根本不知道自己和别人有什么不同。
else. So I imagined that people could recognise a person they hadn't seen for 30 or years that they'd only seen for a little while or just noticed someone from a small part of their face. It's just, yeah, I thought everyone was doing the same thing. And I was reading a crime novel, and in that novel, the story tells of the detective who calls on the Super Recogniser unit at Scotland Yard to send them some help. So I googled the term Super Recogniser and found one of Josh's tests, did the test, and the rest is history. So yes, I had no idea at all that I had this skill, and it turns out that it was something quite rare. And do you have any examples of, from your daily lifetimes that you've recognized somebody from long ago or totally out of context?
所以我以为每个人都能认出他们只见过一小会儿、或者已经有30多年没见的人，或者仅仅通过脸部的一小部分就能认出某人。是的，我以为每个人都在做同样的事情。当时我正在读一本犯罪小说，小说里讲到侦探请求苏格兰场的超级识别者小组提供帮助。于是我谷歌搜索了“超级识别者”这个词，找到了乔什的一个测试，做了测试，剩下的就是历史了。所以是的，我完全不知道自己有这项技能，事实证明这是一种非常罕见的能力。那么，在你的日常生活中，有没有从很久以前或者完全不同的背景下认出某人的例子？
I suppose there's two ways to explain it. One is somebody you know vaguely and somebody you don't know. And that's the really big one is the don't know person. But the example I would give is I was in a local town at a parade. And I just, in a big crowd, I happened to look over my shoulder and I saw a girl stood a few people behind me. And I just glimpsed her for a split second. And in that split second, I knew that that was Amber, who is the sister of a girl I went to kindergarten with 36 years prior.
我想有两种方式可以解释。一种是你认识的人，另一种是你根本不认识的人。而最厉害的是后者，即“不认识的人”。我举个例子，我在当地小镇参加游行。在拥挤的人群中，我碰巧回头看了一眼，看到一个女孩站在我身后几个人远的地方。我只是瞥了她一眼，就那一瞬间，我就知道那是安珀，她是我36年前上幼儿园时一个女孩的妹妹。
And she wasn't even my friend. She was my friend's sister, who I think I saw a couple of times when I went around to play at my friend's house. But it was just that split second. And I worked out that it was 36 years since I would have last saw her. But again, at the time, I didn't know I was doing anything weird. I thought that was normal. And I would bound up to people and say, oh, my goodness.
她甚至不是我的朋友。她是我朋友的妹妹，我想我以前去朋友家玩时见过她几次。但就那一瞬间。我算了一下，距离我上次见到她已经过去36年了。但同样，当时我并不知道自己在做奇怪的事情。我以为那是正常的。我会冲向别人说：“天哪，我真不敢相信。嘿，你好吗？”他们只会一脸茫然地看着我，好像我是个彻头彻尾的疯子。我会说：“是我，我是凯莉。”心想，他们显然忘了我是谁，我是一个容易被遗忘的人。但我猜，超级识别者工作方式的一个最好例子是：在一次体育赛事中，我拿到了一名我们正在寻找的已知犯罪分子的照片。我看了他的脸大概两三秒钟，这就在我脑海中留下了印记，然后我进入了人群。那天人群中有42,000人，我成功找到了他并提醒安保人员他的存在。这就是超级识别者能做到的事情。
I can't believe it. It's hit, hi, how you doing? And they would just look at me blankly as I was a complete loon. And I would say, it's me, it's Kelly, and thinking, you know, they've clearly forgotten who I am and I'm a forgettable type of person. But I guess, I guess an example of the way a super recogniser works that illustrates it best is I was given the image of a known predator that we were looking for at a sporting event. I looked his face for maybe two or three seconds and that imprinted it in my mind and I went into the crowd. And on that day in that crowd, there were 42,000 people there and I was able to find him and alert security to his presence there. So that's what a super recogniser can do.
这听起来简直是奇迹。那么乔什，关于超级识别者是如何做到这一点的，我们知道些什么？我们从脑成像研究或其他研究中有什么线索吗？首先，我们认为这很可能是遗传的。至少面部识别能力似乎具有遗传成分，因为如果像一些研究人员那样进行双胞胎研究，他们会发现同卵双胞胎在面部识别测试中的得分往往比异卵双胞胎相似得多。当然，同卵双胞胎共享100%的基因，而异卵双胞胎共享的基因较少。因此，这似乎说明我们确实有遗传成分。事实上，我们做了一些父母和子女的测试，确实发现父母的能力与子女的能力之间存在相关性，超级识别者的子女往往比对照组的子女得分更高。所以确实存在这种遗传联系。
That just sounds miraculous. So Josh, what do we know about how super recognizers are able to do this? Do we have clues from brain imaging research or other studies? We think, first of all, that it's probably inherited. At least face recognition ability seems to have a genetic component because if you run twin studies, as some researchers have done, they find that identical twins tend to score far more similarly on face recognition tests than non-identical twins. And as of course, identical twins share 100% of their genes and non-identical twins share less of their genes. Therefore, that seems to illustrate that we do have a genetic component. And in fact, we have done some parents and child testing, and we do find a correlation between a parent's ability and their child's ability and super recognizers score slightly higher than, sorry, the children of super recognises tend to score higher than the children of controls. So there's that genetic link.
面部识别似乎也与你的经历有关。一个非常明显的例子是，大多数人识别自己种族面孔的能力要优于其他种族。这在不同年龄段之间似乎也存在同样的情况。我们发现，在一项研究中，我们让超级识别者识别婴儿的脸。这与凯莉描述的情况正好相反。我们发现，成年超级识别者在识别婴儿面孔方面比对照组更强。
there does seem to be from face recognition something to do with your experiences as well. And a very obvious example here is that most people are better at recognising faces of their own ethnicity than of other faces. And it seems to happen with ages versus other ages as well. And we've found that we had one super recogniser in a study in particular. we asked super recognisers to recognise baby faces. It's sort of the opposite to what Kelly is describing. And we found that adult super recognisers were better than controls at recognising baby faces.
但在我们的样本中，碰巧有一位经常与婴儿打交道的医生。她的得分是唯一在婴儿面部测试中高于成人面部测试的，因为她习惯了这些面孔。所以经验也在驱动着这种能力。这似乎是关键因素。凯莉，你谈到认出了一个从幼儿园起就没见过的人，他显然现在已经是个成年人了。你认出小时候认识的人，35年后还能认出是同一个人，这很常见吗？
But in our sample, we coincidentally had a doctor who worked with babies all the time. And her scores were the only ones who were actually higher. on the baby face test than the adult face test because she was used to faces. So there is something driving it with experience as well. And that seems to be the key factors. Kelly, you talked about recognizing somebody you hadn't seen since kindergarten, who clearly was now an adult. Is that common for you that you know somebody as a child and you see them 35 years later
即使他们发生了巨大的变化？是的，看来时间在其中并没有起到什么作用。面部特征必须保持足够的相似性，我才能认出他们，但即使相隔20年、30年甚至更久，或者他们当时是孩子，现在是成年人，我仍然能认出他们。所以是的，我也能认出那些外貌发生了巨大变化的人。他们可能留了胡子、换了完全不同的发型、换了发色。
and you know it's the same person, even though they've radically changed? Yeah, it appears that. time doesn't seem to really play a part in this. The facial features must say similar enough for me to be able to recognise it, but there can be 20, 30 more than that years apart or they were a child, now they're an adult and I can still tell them apart. So yeah, I can also recognise people who've drastically changed their appearance. So they might have facial hair, completely different hairstyle, different hair colour.
所以面部特征似乎总是印在脑海里，我能捕捉到它们。我可以补充一点吗？我的意思是，关于超级识别者的最初研究是在他们出名之前进行的测试。这是哈佛大学的研究人员做的。实际上，他们展示了名人小时候的照片。超级识别者在做这类测试时总是要好得多。当我给超级识别者或其他人群做演讲时，我们经常用这个作为演示。你会展示，比如，布兰妮·斯皮尔斯小时候的照片，超级识别者，
So it seems like the facial features will always remain imprinted and I can pick them up. Can I add to that? I mean, the very first research on super recognisers used before they were famous test. This was by researchers in Harvard. And effectively, they showed famous people's photographs when they were children. And the super recognisers are always far better at doing that type of test. We quite often use that as a demonstration when I'm giving talks to super recognises or other people. And you'll show, I don't know, a child image of, say, Britney Spears and super recognises,
他们几乎立刻就举手了，比其他人快得多地认出了布兰妮。而能力一般的人通常只是坐在那里说：“没人能做到这一点，因为这不可能。”所以确实发生了什么。我们也使用了一种不熟悉的投影方式。你会展示一张成年人的脸和三个婴儿。其中一个是那个成年人。超级识别者在那个测试中往往得分更高。
they've almost got their hands up almost immediately identifying Brittany far quicker than everybody else. And, you know, people with average ability quite often just sit there going, no one can do this because it's impossible. So something is happening. And we've used an unfamiliar type of project as well. Well, you'll show an adult face with three babies. One of them is the adult. And super recognisers tend to score higher on that one.
然而他们从未见过那些婴儿或成年人。那么，凯莉，当你看着一张脸时，你知道自己在看什么吗？你专注于任何特定的细节，还是你只是得到一个整体的图像？是的，是后者。我没有在看细节。我只是知道。那是一瞬间的事。这是一个突然出现在我脑海里的决定。所以，是的，我不知道科学原理是什么，乔什也许能详细说明，或者我想他们还在研究中，对吧，乔什？但我感觉我看到了整体。我看到了形状。我看到了一个形状。所以我甚至能从后脑勺认出人来。这告诉我，我看到的是一个人的形状，而不是面部特征。
And yet they've never met the babies or the adults. So, Kelly, are you aware of what you're looking at when you look at a face? Do you focus on anything in specific or you just get like a boom image of the whole? phase. Yeah, the latter. I'm not looking at details. I just know. It's a split second. It's a decision that just pops into my head. So, yeah, I don't know how the science works and Josh might be able to elaborate or I think they're still looking into it, right, Josh? But I feel like I see the hole. I see the shape. I see a shape. So I can get people from the backs of their heads too. So that tells me that I'm seeing a shape of someone rather than the facial features.
而且我可以通过他们脸部的一小部分认出他们，或者如果他们戴着口罩，我可以通过他们的眼睛认出他们。所以口罩并没有造成识别人的问题。所以在整个疫情期间，这并没有影响你基本工作的能力，对吧？没有。没有，虽然没那么容易。别误会我的意思。但如果你确实看到了你要找的人，那种瞬间的识别感依然存在。我可以补充一点，我们做过研究。我们发现超级识别者在识别戴口罩的人脸时，无论他们是否熟悉，都比对照组更强。
And also I can tell them from just a small part of their face or if they're wearing a mask, I can tell them from their eyes. So the masks haven't caused a problem in identifying people. So throughout the pandemic, it hasn't impaired your ability to basically do your job, right? No. No, it's not as easy. Don't get me wrong. but there's still that instantaneous recognition if you do see the person you're looking for. I could add to that that we have done research. We found super recognisers were better than controls at recognising faces with face masks on, whether they were familiar with them or unfamiliar.
凯莉说的另一件事让我印象深刻，我们还使用脑电图（EEG）测量了大脑活动。我们还发现，与对照组相比，超级识别者在看到熟悉的面孔时，在面部处理的早期阶段似乎有更大的活动峰值。这可能与凯莉所说的能够瞬间认出熟悉的人有关。但这确实需要一些重复验证。它发表在《皮层》（Cortex）杂志上，这是一本相当不错的期刊。
And something else that Kelly said that strikes me was that we have done research using EEG as well, measuring brain activity. And we also found that super recognises seem to have a greater spike of activity very early in face processing when they saw a face that was familiar to them in comparison to controls. And that might link to what Kelly said about sort of instantaneously being able to recognize as someone familiar to them as well. But that does need some replication. It was published in Cortex, which is quite a nice journal to get published in.
那么乔什，目前你知道大脑的哪些部分参与了识别吗？那项特定的研究是脑电图，它测量的是活动。如果你愿意的话，它在地理上定位大脑中活跃区域的能力并不是很好。但其他人做过功能性磁共振成像（fMRI）研究，这在测量大脑方面要精确得多。有一个似乎与面部识别相关的区域，叫做梭状回。当该区域受损时，例如，人们通常会患上面孔失认症，
So you know which part of the brain or parts of the brain are involved in recognition at this point, Josh? That particular research was EEG, which measures activity. And if you like, it's not very good at geographically mapping the areas in the brain that is active at the time. But other people have done fMRI studies, which is far more accurate. at measuring the brain. And there's an area that seems to be associated with face recognition called the fusiform gyrus. And when that area gets damaged, for instance, people often develop prosopagnosia,
正如你介绍这个话题时所说的那样，变得面孔失认。所以fMRI也有很多证据。当人们观看面孔时，它会更加活跃。那么，凯莉，我必须代表我们的露·温纳曼问你一个问题，她是同卵双胞胎的母亲。同卵双胞胎在你看来一直都长得不一样吗？完全不同。是的，我的家人里有同卵双胞胎。当他们还小的时候，我花了很多时间和他们在一起。所以当他们是蹒跚学步的孩子时。我把他们看作两张完全不同的脸。同样，我希望当时我知道为什么我会那样看。但没有，他们只是，在瞥一眼或侧面看时，我就知道哪一个是柯斯蒂，哪一个是莱西。是的，虽然我完全理解他们看起来有多么相似，显然，
as you introduce the topic and become face blind. So there is a lot of evidence from fMRI as well. It's more active when people are viewing faces. So, Kelly, I have to ask you a question on behalf of our pretty Lou Wynerman, who is the mother of identical twins. Do identical twins look different to you all the time? Completely. Yeah, I have identical twins in my family. And I spent a lot of time with them when they were younger. So when they were toddlers. And I saw them as two completely separate faces. And again, I wish I'd have known why I was seeing that at the time. But no, they just, again, in a glimpse or a side view, they would just, I would know, which one was Kirsty and which one was Lacey. And yeah, although I fully appreciate how similar they look, obviously,
但我完全能把他们区分开来。对我来说，差异是显而易见的。好吧，让我问你们两个，超级识别者在生活的其他领域是否有高于平均水平的记忆力？嗯，我可以回答这个问题。我们使用了物体记忆测试和其他一些视觉处理测试，他们往往在这些测试中比对照组稍微好一点，这表明他们确实在视觉事物的记忆方面具有优势，但实际上，当涉及到面孔时，对照组和超级识别者之间的差异要大得多。也许我们也发现了声音方面的差异。
but I can completely tell them apart. They're just, the differences are glaringly obvious to me. Well, let me ask you both, this one, do super recognisers have better than average memory in any other areas of life? Well, I can answer that. We have used object memory tests and some other sort of visual processing tests, and they tend to be slightly better than controls at these other tests, suggesting that they do have superior, you know, memory for visual things in general, but actually the differences between controls and super recognises are far greater when it comes to faces. And perhaps we found voices as well.
我们最近做了一些研究，发现他们在声音方面往往稍微好一点，这可能表明这与人类识别、人类辨认有关，而不仅仅是纯粹的面部识别。凯莉一直描述她有时通过后脑勺等其他特征来识别人的能力。所以这不仅仅是关于脸。你刚才也提到了语音识别。这是目前另一个正在兴起的研究领域吗，即人们可以仅仅根据听到的声音来判断某人是谁？是的，我有一位博士生瑞安·詹金斯，他一直在研究语音识别。我们发现，具有面部超级识别能力的人往往在声音方面也更强。但这绝不是100%。
We've done some recent research, finding that they tend to be slightly better at voices, which might suggest that it's something about. human identification, human recognition, rather than purely face recognition. Kelly's always described her ability to recognize people by other things from the back of the head sometimes. So it's not just about the face. And you just mentioned voice recognition as well. Is that another burgeoning area of research right now that people can just tell who someone is based on hearing their voice? Yeah, so I have a PhD student, Ryan Jenkins, who's been researching voice recognition. We find that people with super recognition ability for faces tend to be better at voices as well. But it's not 100% by any means.
这只是一小部分。所以这项研究正在进行中。其中一件事是开发测试来实际测量这种能力，这总是比你开始攻读博士学位时想象的要难一点。所以几分钟前，乔什提到这有遗传成分。那么，凯莉，你的家人里还有其他人有这种能力吗？我想我妈妈可能也有。她做过一些事情，我认为这表明了这一点。她在一个公共花园的地板上发现了一部手机，
It's a small proportion. So that research is ongoing. One of the things is developing tests to actually measure this ability is always a bit harder than it. Perhaps you imagine when you start down this PhD progress. So a few minutes ago, Josh mentioned that there's a genetic component to this. So, Kelly, are there other people in your family who have this ability? I think that my mum, my mother might have it. So she's pulled some stunts that I think that would suggest that she found a phone,
一部iPhone。她捡起来，有人正在给它打电话，屏幕上显示了打电话人的脸。她知道她刚刚走过那个人。所以她把它还给了他们。所以我说：“嗯，妈妈，我想也许这里面有什么名堂。”所以是的，我会说她有很高的潜力。所以她没有参加测试？她没有。
an iPhone on the floor in a public garden. And she picked it up and it was somebody was calling it and it showed the face of the person calling. And she knew she'd just walk past that person. So she took it back to them. So I said, hmm, mom, I think maybe something's going on here. So yeah, I would say she's a high, she's got a high potential there. So she hasn't taken the test? She hasn't.
她可能太害怕失败了。我会鼓励她的。那么面部识别能力是你可以通过训练自己去做，甚至只是为了变得更好吗？一些研究人员试图教人们提高面部识别能力，特别是在护照官员等身份验证角色中，因为这非常重要。所以也许你可以通过要求人们专注于面部的特征或其他方面，稍微提高执行面部匹配任务的能力，
She's probably too scared to fail. I'm going to encourage her. So is facial recognition? ability, something you can train yourself to do or even to just get better at? Some researchers have tried to teach people to be better at face recognition, in particular in perhaps the sort of identity verification role such as passport officers, because that's so important. So perhaps you can improve slightly the ability to perhaps do a face matching task by asking people to focus on features or other aspects of the face,
这种训练方案似乎并不能提高一般的面部识别能力。所以恐怕你的能力在30岁左右达到顶峰，在青少年时期之后会持续提高，但从那一点开始，就会出现漫长而不幸的缓慢下降。好吧，那么凯莉，幸运的是你也是一名专业摄影师，这也是一个视觉领域。你觉得它和你的超级识别能力有任何联系吗？你只拍肖像吗？
it doesn't seem to improve face recognition in general, this type of training scheme. So I'm afraid your ability seems to peak at about 30 years of age, keeps improving beyond the teenage years, but then there's a long, unfortunate slow decline from that point on. Well, then perhaps it's lucky, Kelly, that you also are a professional photographer. which is also a visual field. Do you feel that it's linked in any way to your super recognising ability? And do you only take portraits?
不，我做各种商业摄影。所以老实说，我不认为它有联系。超级识别者来自各行各业，拥有各种不同的技能。我看不出有什么模式。我在工作中非常注重细节。而且我一丝不苟。这对我工作有帮助。
No, I do all sorts of commercial photography. So I don't think it's linked, to be honest with you. There's all sorts of different people from different walks of life, different skills that are super recognisers. And I can't see a pattern there. I put a lot of attention to detail in my work. And I am meticulous. And that helps with my job.
但我看不出有什么联系。我看不出那里有什么联系。好吧，说到工作，正如我在介绍中提到的，你的另一份工作是为“国际超级识别者”工作，从事调查和安全识别工作。你和什么样的组织合作，在平均的一天里你为他们做什么？是的，我为执法机构、警察部门、安保、私人保安公司工作。我们做各种各样的事情，正如你提到的，从谋杀调查、
but I don't see a link. I don't see a link there. Well, speaking of jobs, your other job, as I mentioned in the intro, was that you work for Super Recognizers International doing investigative and security identification work. What kind of organizations do you work with and what do you do for them on an average day? Yeah, I work for law enforcement agencies, police departments, security, private security companies. And we do all sorts of things from, as you mentioned, murder investigations,
袭击调查，一直到现场活动，我们在现场进行秘密行动，在人群中寻找目标。所以我们可以应用这项技能的方式多种多样。我们可以为那些试图证明某人身份的人制作面部对比报告。所以工作非常多样化，我也在处理一些快速发展的调查，例如失踪人口、被贩卖和剥削的儿童。我为NCPTF工作，也就是美国的国家儿童保护工作组，他们在美国做着令人惊叹的工作，调查失踪儿童并营救他们。他们作为一个全球志愿者力量，共同努力提供帮助，真是太棒了。
assault investigations through to live events where we're on foot doing, you know, covert operations, looking for people in crowds. So there's a variety of ways in which we can apply the skill. We can produce facial comparison reports for people who are trying to prove the identity of somebody. So it's very varied and I'm also working on quite quick moving investigations such as missing people, trafficked and exploited children. I work for the NCPTF, which is the National Child Protection Task Force over in America there, who do an amazing job investigating missing children and rescuing them. They're amazing as a global force that are volunteering together to help.
我是他们喜欢称之为“变种人”的一员。他们有一个拥有各种不同技能的团队。我很自豪地说我是其中之一，变种人。所以，是的，这就是我们正在做的事情。你自己找到过失踪儿童吗？是的。那一定非常非常有成就感。确实是。
And I'm one of their what they'd like to call mutants. They have a team of all sorts of different skills. and I'm proud to say I'm one of them, mutants. So, yeah, that's the sort of thing we're doing. And have you found missing children yourself? Yeah. That must be very, very satisfying. It is.
我能得到一些我们知道正在被剥削的儿童的面孔。我们也有犯罪分子。我有一个案例，我们有一个犯罪分子和两个孩子联系在一起。我能够在网上找到他们的联系，在我识别出他们大约六个小时后，我们就找到了他们。所以我的线索会交给正在调查此案的警察部门。显然，我不仅仅是说“就是他们，去抓他们”。他们必须进行彻底的调查。所以我只是提供线索。
I'm able to be given some faces of children that we know are being exploited. We have the predator as well. I had a case where we had a predator and two children linked together. I was able to find links to them online and we picked them up around six hours after I identified them. So my leads will be given to the police department who are investigating that. So obviously I don't just say it's them, go get them. They will have to do a thorough investigation. So I'm just the lead.
然后这为他们节省了数天、数周、数月的搜索和排查时间。我可以非常快地给他们结果。然后他们可以跟进这些线索。在那起案件中，在他们被救出和犯罪分子被捕前六个小时。所以，是的，我们正在取得一些辉煌的成果。我们在谋杀调查中也取得了一些伟大的成果，我的证据帮助警方缩小了时间线，
And then it saves them days, weeks, months of searching and trawling. I can get them results really quickly. then they can follow those leads. And in that case, six hours before they were, the kids were rescued and the predator was arrested. So, yeah, we're getting some brilliant results. We've had some great results in murder investigations too where my evidence has helped to narrow down timelines for the police
并改善了预谋的认定。所以我可以为检方制作一套很好的证据包。近年来，我们听到了很多关于人工智能、面部识别算法以及它们如何被用于从社交媒体到警务的方方面面的信息。好吧，这显然存在一些伦理和法律问题，但作为一个纯粹的实际问题，超级识别者和人工智能算法一样好吗，还是他们更好？
and improve premeditation. So I can create a nice package of evidence for the prosecution. In recent years, we've heard a lot about artificial intelligence, facial identification algorithms, and how they're being used in everything from social media to policing? Well, there are obviously some ethical and legal questions around this, but just as a purely practical question, are super recognisers as good as AI algorithms, or are they better?
所以关于这个的最后一份大型研究实际上是在美国完成的。他们招募了超级识别者、对照组，还有法医面部分析师，以及当时美国国家科学技术研究院认定的最佳算法。他们发现超级识别者的操作水平与最佳算法相当，并且远好于对照组。但他们还发现了一点，我认为这是这里的关键，实际上如果你
So the last big piece of research really on this was done in the United States. And they recruited super recognizers, controls, also forensic facial analysts. and the best algorithms at the time, as identified by the National Institute of Science and Technology in the USA. And they found that the super recognisers were operating at the same level as the best algorithms and far better than controls. But what they also found, which I think is really key here, is that actually if you
将超级识别者的决策与算法相结合，准确率甚至更高。原因之一是算法会犯人类永远不会犯的错误，而人类会犯算法可能不会犯的错误。因此，你消除了那些可能对两者都独特的错误，从而获得了更好的结果。人工智能有凯莉描述的那种能力吗，即她能从后脑勺认出人来？几乎肯定没有。我不认为，因为人工智能必须接受训练。
combined the decision-making of a super-recogniser with an algorithm, accuracy was even, higher. And one of the reasons is because algorithms make mistakes that a human would never make, and humans make mistakes that an algorithm probably wouldn't make. So therefore, you're removing those errors that are probably unique to both and getting better outcomes. Does AI have the ability that Kelly described, which is she can tell people from seeing the backs of their heads? Almost certainly not. I don't think because AI has to be trained. with images for it to be able to perform these tasks. And I don't think there are any databases of faces from the back of the head to train AI.
必须有图像才能执行这些任务。而且我认为没有任何从后脑勺拍摄的面部数据库来训练人工智能。所以这就是它的工作原理。你必须把成百上千甚至上万张脸扔进混合物中，人工智能才能最有效，有点像人类。如果你没有那些图像，那么人类每次都会打败人工智能。而且我们还可以处理质量非常低的图像。你知道，非常像素化的图像不会阻碍我们。而且，就像我说的，口罩、胡子、可能干扰算法的零碎东西，我们都可以，我们某种程度上会覆盖这些。所以我认为我是面部识别软件的坚定拥护者，我喜欢与它合作。
So that's how it works. You have to sort of throw into the mix hundreds, if not thousands of faces for AI to be most effective, a bit like humans. And if you haven't got those images, then humans are going to beat AI every single time. And we can also deal with really low quality images. you know, really pixelated images aren't going to deter us. And also, you know, like I said, masks, facial hair, bits and pieces that might throw an algorithm off, we can, we kind of override those. So I think I am a great advocate of facial recognition software and I enjoy working with
当我与使用面部识别软件的人合作时，我会得到一些最好的结果。所以我认为把我们两个放在一起会产生超能力。那么你的观点是，在海关检查护照的人，我们是否应该在他们获得这类工作之前测试他们的面部识别能力？绝对应该，而且有些国家确实这么做了。你永远不会想要一个面孔失认症患者担任护照官员，因为他们根本无法胜任这项工作。我不一定确定那份工作需要超级识别者，但你想要的是在这些岗位上具有高于平均水平能力的人，因为他们更有可能做出正确的识别，而且他们也更有可能不会做出错误的识别，这比能力一般或较低的人要好。这也是关键。凯莉，你工作的公司是否提倡这一点？我的意思是，你是否咨询过，
it. I get some of my best results when I team up with guys that use facial recognition software. So I think putting the two of us together makes a superpower. So is it your view that people who check passports, say, in customs, should we be testing people for their facial recognition ability before they get jobs like this? Absolutely, and they do in some countries. You would never want someone with face blindness, prosopagnosia being a passport officer because they just could not do the job. I'm not necessarily sure that you need super recognisers for that job, but what you want is people who have above average abilities in those sorts of roles because they're far more likely to make a correct identification, but they're also far more likely not to make a wrong. identification than people with average or lower ability. That's key as well. Kelly, is a company that you work for, advocate for this? I mean, do you consult to,
你知道，可能可以使用某种员工测试的操作？绝对的。我们与许多不同的公司合作提供协助。我们为一家评估护照照片和身份证照片的公司工作。所以，是的，这绝对是我们能够应用和帮助的事情。我们通过测试识别超级识别者，然后让他们参加我们自己的培训课程，我们会教他们所有关于图像使用法律的知识。如果我们在外活动，它还会增强他们的行为分析技能。所以我们也可以增强超级识别周围的技能，打造一个真正全面的超级识别者，能够走向世界并利用他们的技能造福社会。
you know, operations that maybe could use some sort of a test for their employees? Absolutely. We team up with lots of different companies to assist. We work for a company that do assess passport photographs and ID photos. So, yeah, it's definitely something we can apply and help with. And we do identify super recognisers through the testing and then we put them through our own training courses, which we'll teach them all about the law surrounding image use. It will enhance their skills with behavioural analysis as well if we're actually out and about. So we can enhance skills around super recognition too to make a really rounded super recognises that's able to go out into the world and use their skill for good.
所以我们的一些听众可能不知道，在你们的国家，你们都在英国，闭路电视几乎无处不在，对吧？你们一直都在摄像头的监控下。这与美国有点不同，在美国，我们对这个概念非常敏感。你们所做的事情，例如试图寻找罪犯，是否存在伦理问题？我的意思是，英国人是否觉得他们的隐私受到了侵犯？所以他们确实担心计算机化面部识别系统方面的隐私，这是肯定的。但我认为没有人担心超级识别者，因为，如果你愿意的话，他们体现了一个老派警察应该能够做到的事情。
So some of our listeners might not be aware that in your country and you're both in England, that there are closed circuit TVs pretty much everywhere, right? You folks are on camera all the time. It's a little different from the U.S. where, you know, we're very sort of hinky about that concept. Are there ethical issues surrounding what it is that you do, for example, trying to find criminals? I mean, do people in England feel like their privacy has been invaded? So they do worry about privacy in terms of computerized face recognition systems, definitely. But I don't think anybody worries about super recognises because, if you like, they epitomize what an old-fashioned police officer should be able to do.
他们认识所有的罪犯。你在警察节目中看到过。在警务工作中，超级识别者识别罪犯并没有什么奇怪的。识别罪犯和类似的人。每个人都期待它。他们对算法更怀疑，这是肯定的。而且被摄像头监控对我们来说是一种生活方式。我宁愿我的整个国家都被摄像头覆盖，
They know all the criminals. You see it on cop shows. There's nothing strange about super-recognizers within policing identifying criminals. identifying criminals and people like that. Everyone expects it. It's the algorithms they are more suspicious of, definitely. And it's a way of life for us being on camera. I would far rather that my whole country was covered in cameras
如果我或我的亲人发生了什么事，它会被捕捉到，我们将有一些证据可以利用。通过监控录像解决的案件数量，因为这个原因而更快、更准确地得出结论，我坚信我们应该在到处安装摄像头。我当然在我的房子里到处都装了。我没有。
and if something happens to me or one of my loved ones that it's going to get picked up and we're going to have some evidence to work from, the number of cases that are solved through surveillance footage and come to a conclusion much quicker and more accurately because of that, I'm a strong believer that we should stick cameras everywhere. And I certainly have them all over my house. I don't.
对我个人而言，我保护我的隐私。但我确实同意在某些领域你确实需要摄像头。你需要在市中心、机场和类似的地方，火车站、旅行中心。而且它们应该受到适当的审查。据我了解，安装摄像头是因为执法部门认为它们会起到威慑作用，但似乎并非如此，很多人只是漫不经心地去犯罪，因为他们认为有成千上万、数百万这样的图像。
For me personally, I'm protective of my privacy. But I do agree there in some areas you do want cameras. You want them in town centres and airports and places like that, train stations, travel centres. And they should be scrutinized properly. So my understanding is that the cameras were installed. because there was the thinking among law enforcement that they would be a deterrent, but it seems that they're not, that a lot of people will just blithely go about committing crimes because they figure there are tens and thousands and millions of these images.
没人能找到我。你觉得公众，至少在英国，是否意识到你们已经能够破解很多案件了？是的，我认为这非常重要。媒体报道的超级识别者的成功案例。事实上，我的博士学位是关于法庭上用于识别目的的面部使用方式。在那个时候，它们根本没有被使用。周围有很多摄像头，没有人真正看过它们。直到后来，他们才开始适当地审查图像，确保他们确实尝试识别在摄像头上犯罪的人。
No one's ever going to find me. Do you feel that the public, at least in the UK, is aware of the fact that you have been able to crack a lot of cases? Yeah, I think it's been very important. the super recognises successes that have been in the media. In fact, my PhD was on the way that faces are used in court for identification purposes. And at that time, they weren't at all. There was a lot of cameras around and nobody was ever really looking at them. It's only later that they started properly scrutinising the images, making sure that they actually try and identify people committing crimes on camera.
这孕育了成功，更多的成功，你就会识别出更多的罪犯。以至于，你知道，我的工作已经转移到世界各地的其他国家。我们，特别是在目前，我们正在德国警察部队中识别出许多超级识别者，在印度有超级识别者从事身份验证工作，为人们在政府和其他组织检查身份证件的角色中创造了大量工作。我们还没有真正在美国开展工作。但谁知道呢？我正在路上。
And that breeds success, more success, you get more criminals identified. And so much so that, you know, my work has transferred to other countries around the world. We've, especially at the moment we're identifying a lot of super recognises within German police forces, super recognises in India working in identity verification, creating lots of jobs there for people working in sort of roles, checking identity. documents for the government and other organisations. We're not really working in America in the USA as of yet. But who knows? I'm on my way.
我来找你了。所以，凯莉，听起来你真的很欣赏你拥有的这种能力，但我很好奇你是否觉得有什么缺点。我的意思是，人们会试图愚弄你吗？我没看到任何缺点。我认为现在我知道我没有被持续跟踪是一种解脱，因为当然，如果你在购物中心走来走去，一遍又一遍地看到同一个人，你开始认为，我被这个人跟踪了，但本质上发生的是我只是
I'm coming to get you. So, Kelly, I mean, it sounds like you really appreciate this ability that you have, but I'm wondering if you ever feel that there are drawbacks. I mean, do people try to fool you? I don't see any drawbacks. I think it's a relief now I know I'm not being stalked constantly, because of course if you're walking around a shopping mall and you see the same person over and over again, you start to think, I'm being followed by this person, but essentially what's happening is I'm just
在同一个购物中心认出了同一个人。没有比这更糟糕的了。所以老实说，真的没有什么缺点。它非常有用。当我不断告诉周围的人，那是20年前电影里的那个家伙，是《夺宝奇兵3》里的临时演员时，这对周围的人来说有点烦人。但没有，我拥抱这项技能。我很高兴我能用它做好事，我看到的结果对那些失去亲人或为正义而战的家庭来说意味着什么。所以这只是一种荣誉，我
recognizing the same person in the same shopping mall with me. There's nothing worse than that. So there aren't really any drawbacks, to be honest with you. It's very useful. It's a bit annoying for people who are around me when I keep telling them that that's the guy in the film 20 years ago that was an extra in Indiana Jones and the last crusade, you know. But no, it's, I embrace the skill. I'm so delighted that I can use it for good, that I'm seeing results that are meaning things to, it means something to families who have lost somebody or who are fighting for justice. So it's just an honor that I'm
能够将这种技能转化为对社会有用的东西。那么乔什，最后一个问题。研究下一步走向哪里？嗯，这是一个大问题。我们想做更多的脑部扫描研究，试图准确了解超级识别者的大脑中发生了什么。然后也许从中，我们可以了解如何更好地在不同的劳动力中应用他们的技能，因为我们真的不知道未来我们可能会走向哪里，以最好地利用超级识别者。我可能更像是一个应用心理学家，而不是理论心理学家，更感兴趣的是看到，你知道，像凯莉所做的那样实际的应用方面。我们还能如何利用凯莉的技能来，你知道，帮助整个社会？
able to translate this skill into something useful for society. So Josh, last question. Where is the research going next? Well, that's a big question. We would like to do some more brain scanning research to try and understand exactly what's going on in Super Recogniser's brains. And then perhaps from that, we can understand how to better apply their skills in different workforces for whatever reason, because we don't really know where we might end up going in the future for the best use of Super Recognise. I'm probably more of an applied psychologist than a theoretical psychologist, more interested in seeing, you know, the practical aspects work like that Kelly does. How else can we use Kelly's skills to, you know, help society in general?
有没有我们错过了使用超级识别的地方，凯莉？你的公司在寻找什么？你们在扩张吗？是的，我们当然在扩张。我们的热情是帮助执法部门。这就是我们想做的，能够去执法机构，帮助他们识别队伍中的超级识别者，因为会有成百上千的人。如果能识别出他们，帮助培训他们更好地了解自己的技能，并让他们在这些警察部门中得到更好的利用，那将是太棒了。
Are there places that we're missing the use of super recognition, Kelly? What are you looking for in your company? Are you expanding? Yeah, we certainly are. Our passion is to help law enforcement. That's what we would like to do, is to be able to go to law enforcement agencies and help them to identify super recognisers within their ranks because there are going to be hundreds of them. And it would be fantastic to think that we could identify them, helped train them to know their skill better, and for them to be used within those police departments for the better.
所以这就是我们的热情。国际超级识别者很乐意走出去，深入执法机构，帮助他们识别自己的人。这就是我们认为我们能为社会获得最好结果的地方。好吧，我要感谢你们两位今天加入我们。我认为你们都在做着非常重要的工作，我为此感谢你们。非常感谢。非常感谢，金。
So that's our passion. Super recognises international would love to get out there and get amongst the law enforcement agencies to help them identify their own. That's where we think we'd get the best results for society for. Well, I want to thank you both for joining us today. I think you're both doing extraordinarily important work, and I thank you for it. Thank you very much. Thanks so much, Kim.
这就是我们的热情所在。Super Recognisers International非常希望能走出去，深入到执法机构中，帮助他们识别出自己的人员。我们认为，这能为社会带来最好的结果。好了，非常感谢两位今天能参加我们的节目。我认为你们都在做着极其重要的工作，我对此表示感谢。非常感谢。非常感谢，Kim。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you can, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can even, email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condihan.
您可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Stitcher 以及您获取播客的任何平台找到《心理学谈话》往期节目。如果可以，请给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，也可以发送电子邮件至 SpeakingofPsychology@apa.org。即 SpeakingofPsychology（全部连写）@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由 Lee Winerman 制作，我们的音频编辑是 Chris Condihan。
Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的 Kim Mills。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。